Oscar nominations came out yeah Victoria  yeah Joker was nominated for Best  Picture yeah yeah it's about a creepy  misfit in white makeup or as the critics  are calling it the Conan O'Brien story I  saw that one coming - don't worry about  it  Jonathan Pryce and Anthony Hopkins were  both nominated for the two popes yeah  yeah the two popes personally I thought  it was the worst romantic comedy I've  ever seen I like I like that when you  mentioned the two popes somebody went  yeah oh yeah well thanks for that Andy's  no I'm not - what now we're not on the  air my mom hasn't watched in eight years  [Laughter]  the consumer advocacy group 1 Million  Moms has condemned a new Burger King ad  for using the word damn yeah yeah they  also came after Arby's for using the  word meat  [Applause]